an update on a chicago woman who was
targeted by a botched police raid she is
speaking out for the very first time
since the city approved a 2.9 million
dollar settlement with her recently
a warning about this video of the raid
is extremely upsetting this body cam
footage from 2019 shows police officers
breaking down angenette young's door
while she was in the middle of changing
her clothes the officers left this
innocent woman naked and handcuffed for
a very long period of time she
repeatedly asked to get dressed and told
them they were at the wrong address
we spoke with young about the experience
yesterday but first let's take a look
back at what happened that night
this body cam footage from february 2019
shows a dozen male chicago police
officers storming into angenette young's
home on a thursday night
she was in the middle of changing her
clothes after returning from a work
event
young says the officers left her naked
and handcuffed for 40 minutes
they later learned that a police
informant gave them a bad tip
the person they were actually looking
for lived next door and was wearing an
electronic monitoring bracelet
city officials went to court to try to
block this video from airing after young
and her attorney shared it with our
chicago station wbbm
you got the wrong house this incident
happened before i was mayor
but is coming to light as i am mayor and
i have a responsibility to address this
issue chicago mayor lori lightfoot
initially denied knowing what happened
to young but later admitted she had been
briefed on the incident in november 2019
a third-party investigation ordered by
lightfoot found failures in oversight
and accountability by multiple city
agencies but determined that the mayor
and the city did not purposefully
conceal information about the botched
raid
now a newly released summary of a
scathing report by chicago's inspector
general finds the city did work to
prevent young from obtaining body cam
video and that it prioritized
communications and public relations
concerns over the higher mission of city
government
mayoral lightwood says she does not
agree with that conclusion
an oversight agency has recommended that
eight of the officers involved in the
incident be suspended or fired so far
none of them have
and angenette young now joins us in the
studio it's good to see you
thank you for having me you know i
remember antoinette when i first saw
that video it made me so angry and it
made me so sad because i could hear the
fear and i could hear the pain in your
voice as you look at it again what do
you remember about that night
um watching that video is always hard
because it just takes me back to that
moment
and one thing that stands out the most
to me as i think about this and lived
through this over the years is how
vulnerable i was in that moment what
were you doing at the time when the
police officers broke through the door
what were you doing i was getting
undressed
in the fact that i continued to ask if i
could get dressed i continued to ask
them if i could call someone
what stands out to me most is that i was
invisible to them
um because no one even responded to me
saying yes you can get dressed later or
let us finish this like they just
totally ignored me then while you're
standing there news why i'm standing
there nude and pleading yes
how has this experience affected you now
so i tell people that
i didn't lose my life that night
but i lost a lot of my life that night
at some point did you think you could
lose your life
i actually thought that if i had done
anything different than what i was doing
i would have died that night they yell
put your hands up and that's what i did
and i stood there in fear
and praying and hoping that they would
not shoot me last month the city
approved a two point new 2.9 million
dollar settlement for you
is that justice to you
because i could see some people looking
at this and saying well at least she got
paid
um the money is not justice and i never
went into this when i started the legal
um proceedings i never went in looking
for money what were you looking for when
i hired my attorney i immediately told
him that i wanted them all fired and i
say that because in any other profession
if you go to work and you harm someone
in this type of way you lose your job
as a social worker if i go to work and i
harm a client i will lose my job i will
lose my license just last week the
chicago office of inspector general
released a summary of the report and the
summary says that the city did in fact
mishandle your case across the board
so it's validating for me that over the
last three years i've been saying that
i've been saying that this is not right
but it doesn't
add to justice because
they need to make changes in policy
they need to make cultural changes in
the way that the police department
operates and they need to get rid of
some old boys that are in there
training new people to operate in this
way you say cultural changes do you
think the fact that you are a person
that you are a black woman do you think
that played a role in this i absolutely
think it played a role why so not so
much that i'm a black woman but that my
skin color is different from all of the
men who were in that room that night and
that validate to me that they had no
concern or passion for people and
families of color
and they've done this to other families
primarily in the black and brown
communities what happened to me does not
happen in the white
communities in chicago you know and
listen the only reason why we were even
seeing this tape is because you had to
go to court to get the tape yes you
fought to have this tape released yes do
you regret that so many of us have seen
you at your most vulnerable time i do
not don't it was a very hard decision to
agree to allow this to be played yes
but it was very necessary in the sense
that at the point that we
actually were able to get the body cam
footage after many attempts of not being
able to get it it was necessary because
at that point for me it was about i need
to expose what's happening here you know
the mayor hired a private firm to
investigate the case and they came to
the conclusion that the mayor's office
didn't have malicious intent in the
response to the case and they did not
deliberately conceal any information
what are your thoughts about that they
did a public showing of their results in
the entire time
i was in tears watching them stand
before the public and say that they did
nothing wrong
when everyone knows that they hid the
information initially
and then went to court to try to bend
cbs 2 chicago from airing it
the mayor lied continuously that entire
week when the video came out only later
to retract her information so how do you
not call that
intent
when do you think you will finally feel
at peace
i don't ever think that this will go
away i'm choosing to find ways to live
on purpose and not allow this one
incident to define me for the rest of my
life
has the money changed your life
no no no um
the money is almost an insult
in a sense that is saying
okay this is what we value that
situation to be and so
here's some money to help you with that
and even the mayor said you know this
amount of money will allow her to have
resources to take care of herself
there's no amount of money that
will right this wrong
i'm not a very flashy person i really do
enjoy living a simple life where i go
about my day as a social worker and and
i find joy in helping other people so i
would definitely be using this money for
that
cause to help other people
i would have
been
more satisfied
if all 12 officers had got fired and i
didn't receive a dime
wow yeah it's interesting you would
think
the money would bring her some comfort
and she says she wants to use it to help
other people she's a social worker by
training tony and i we both notice the
same thing on the wall where it says
faith hope and love she really is that
type of person she says she now suffers
from ptsd she's easily triggered by loud
things i'm happy to say she no longer
lives in that apartment
but she has not been able to go back to
work because she says mentally she's not
ready and she goes to therapy every
wednesday every wednesday like clockwork
to help her get through this and that
was in 2019. i i was noticing the faith
faith hope love and the other
knickknacks there's a drawing from some
child in her life because it reminds
everybody out there that you may not
know her but you know this person yeah
she's a very familiar person in our
lives and you have to ask yourself what
led to this happening from the police
perspective and how can it never happen
again like these sorts of mistakes need
to be prevented at the root we need to
find that root for a lot of people their
worst fear is being naked in front of
somebody exactly and she was exactly she
stood there nude for 40 minutes yes
ignored her as she was exposed there is
this poetic justice in her strength
saying release the tape yeah at least if
i want people to see me yeah she said
she thought about it nate and now she
has the police in chicago exposed just
like she was you know the thing is
nobody from the police department has
ever apologized to her wow